this is a deep-sea anglerfish mating
pair these animals have rarely been
observed in their natural habitat
hundreds to thousands of metres below
the ocean's surface you're watching one
of the few known videos and this one
shows a sexually parasitic pair for the
first time that means during mating the
tiny male is permanently attached to the
female he gets nutrients and she gets
sperm these specialized fish rarely
survive the journey to the surface
before now most deep-sea anglerfish
studies used dead animals pulled up in
nets and sometimes preserved in museums
in this case the research team used a
special submersible designed to capture
images of creatures that live at these
great depths like most other members of
its order this angler fish is known for
the bioluminescent lure like appendage
that drifts in front of its mouth to
attract prey but this is the first time
that what might be bioluminescence on
the fish's filaments has been documented
the swaying swarm of thin projections
around the angler may act like a 3d
array of cat whiskers sensing danger and
prey in the environment
there's little to eat at the step and it
is very cold
leaving anglerfish with few calories to
spare so it makes sense that as this
video shows the anglerfish female seems
to use very little energy slowly
drifting and rolling through the water
but we don't know much about their
metabolism the bacteria that supply
their glow or how the female's body
doesn't reject the males the special
ship that took this video has been in
operation since 2013 and there aren't
many like it in the world so chances are
many anglerfish mysteries will stay that
way for some time to come
Oh